George Clooney fires back at a French
magazine for publishing photos of his
twin the 56 year old actor revealed on
Friday that he plans to prosecute Block
C magazine for he says secretly taking
and publishing paparazzi pics of his
newborn children whom he shares with his
wife Amal
in a statement to ET George says quote
over the last week photographers from
Block C magazine scaled our fence
climbed our tree and illegally took
pictures of our infants inside our home
adding quotes make no mistake the
photographer's the agency and the
magazine will be prosecuted to the full
extent of the law the safety of our
children demands it the mag printed too
blurry photos on the cover of their
latest issue one of George and one of
them all holding one and a half month
old twins Ella and Alexander at the
Actors Lake Como estate in Italy the
French outlet responded to Clooney
saying in part quote people love George
Clooney and have been following his life
story for years now those pictures do
not put in danger mr. Clooney his wife
for their kids any official approved
photos of ella and alexander has yet to
be released
[Music]
you